we're still here in Miami coach Tony
Dungy joining us for another segment as
we get closer and closer to Super Bowl
54 and you know coach this is a strange
game for me because it isn't all that
complicated to understand where the
pressure points are if the 49ers can run
the ball the way we've seen them run at
all postseason long the Chiefs are gonna
have a hard time stopping them from
scoring points and if the 49ers front
four can get to Patrick mahomes then the
Chiefs gonna have a hard time scoring
points and if they can't then it could
be a shootout I mean it's it's very very
simple in the big picture stuff and we
talked earlier about the Chiefs from the
49ers standpoint do you think the Chiefs
can slow them down we saw them slow down
Derrick Henry in the championship game
can they slow down this 49ers running
into me Chris Jones is such a key right
this Jones to me is like Bob Sanders was
for us that Chiefs defense we saw a
couple of weeks where we just saved
what's going on right he comes in and
and against Tennessee I don't think they
were gonna play him a lot and then he's
got a little Dyke there and we got going
right he came in made a couple plays a
tackle for a loss disrupted the pocket
and now that second half he's in more
and more and so to me his health is a
big key can he play 50 plays and can he
give them that push inside because that
that's what they're gonna need it they
can't stop that inside running it'll be
a long day but to me he entire and
Matthew of the keys yeah you you your
gut feeling though if he's there healthy
that you think they could at least slow
it down I think is a more energy right
he just gives them a sense that we can
do this and that that was missing during
during certain parts of the year what is
it to you just ex defensive brewing in
mind when you break down the run game of
the 49ers and you look at it that just
is like that jumps out to you you know
they're they're very precise at what
they do they block things a certain way
they they have a good sense of what runs
are gonna be effective against each team
and I go back to Bobby Turner I played
against he's their running backs it's a
legend played against Mike Shanahan
coach teams and you know it doesn't
matter hey Terrell Davis or Landis Gary
Tatum Bell is you know player after
player after player would go in and he
tell
doesn't hate there's gonna be a hole you
get one cut and good I want you to burst
through it right dance you'll be on the
sidelines with me right and so those
guys go in and you see how hard they run
no no it's whether it's most dirt or
Tevin Kevin Coleman was not a
north/south guy right in Atlanta right
and he's turned into that he's made
inside runs so I think it's just a
mindset that hey we're gonna get a hole
and we're gonna be effective and you're
gonna run through it the other thing I
like to talk about with those guys we
always talk about defensive front sevens
yeah this offensive front seven when you
include George Kittel and Kyle use tech
yeah they've got as good a front seven
blocking unit as anybody in football
yeah how do you balance a defensive
coach with like okay I know we got to do
maybe some creative things and the week
of the Super Bowl we want to throw a few
curveballs at him but not overdoing it
yeah and I don't think you can throw
curve balls but I think it's what do we
give up okay we're gonna have to commit
Tyrann Mathieu is gonna have to be down
there close to the line of scrimmage
we're gonna have to get a tackler in
there how are we gonna cheat on Kittel
are we gonna cheat on debo Samuel I'm
gonna cheat on Emmanuel Sanders who are
we gonna give up to get this running
game stop and to me that's what Kyle is
gonna have to figure out okay this is
what they're doing who's gonna be the
hot man in the past yeah okay so if the
Chiefs have success in slowing down the
running game then the focus falls to
quarterback Jimmy Garoppolo who had
eight passes against the Packers who in
the second half of the game against the
Vikings hardly threw the ball at all
well and that to me was the key we were
at the game and he threw a ball that
should have been in a cept about three
of them and then he threw an
interception right after that it was
like okay we are you know we don't trust
you you're out of the trust tree right
right it if they can do that if they can
get them where they don't just feel like
hey we can mask these guys and run the
ball it's gonna have to be a balanced
game it'll be interesting to see how the
49ers react and and if they in fact go
to letting Jimmy be creative and I think
that the message that we detected it
can't be lost on the players even though
they say all the right things
that's to defend their guy internally
they have to be thinking what's gonna
happen if we can't run the ball and
Jimmy has to throw it and we get near
misses and maybe they won't be near
misses this time around maybe Tyrann
Mathieu pops up out of nowhere and picks
off the ball and it changes the entire
complexion of the game and it also that
they've been ahead in these games and
that is a big advantage to the 49ers
style of offense
I remember 2004 I was at Indy we're
playing Mike Shanahan and Denver
we played them like week 16 yeah next to
last game in Indy and they ran the ball
just like these guys and run it they
kept the ball about 48 minutes we didn't
have it and they beat us in Indy two
weeks later they come back in the
playoff game we won the toss we scored
we got a head something happened third
down play we stopped them and now all of
a sudden were up two scores right I
remember game they they couldn't be bad
you couldn't it wasn't now they're out
of their element in the right type of
game so again how does the game start as
mahomes get going early did they get the
leads they've looked san francisco's
looks so dominant in these last two
games it's hard to think they have flaws
but then before that there's all these
last play of the game situation so
struggled down the stretch in a regular
season
you know I one thing like I you know you
talk about the 49ers defense I don't
think people really give you credit for
this and I just want to kind of put this
out there like the Seattle scheme and
everything they're really kind of
originates from the Tampa two and
evolved from there I mean with some of
the coaches down there that I was with
in Tampa and Monte Kiffin and okay it's
Tampa to Tampa too but they started to
really become more of a cover three
scheme and I know you've really ran more
cover three towards the end than
Indianapolis and Tampa to kind of just
talk about that what people don't
understand I think about that whole
concept is it wasn't covered to
necessarily it wasn't a coverage it was
a philosophy that we're gonna be
dominant up front we're gonna have these
fast guys that we can rush for guys and
and get to the passer and then we're
gonna play a lot of zone coverage it
could be all kinds of zones but we're
gonna have seven sets of eyes
portable and we're going to not give up
big play right so Monte Kiffin really
perfects this Gus Bradley comes to work
for him and then it morphs into he goes
to Seattle yeah Carroll and all the guys
who came from the Seattle tree you know
now Atlanta wind Bradley Roberts all
Jaguars alright and yeah and so San
Francisco now does a lot of the same
thing it's three deep zone right a great
extent and a lot of that and to me
that's gonna be the key for Kansas City
Patrick mahomes may have to throw the
ball quick but if there's a lot of zone
a my patient enough to take that short
pass before the pressure gets there
right and then make San Francisco do
something they don't want to do
necessarily which is play man and yeah
right right I get the impression you're
leaning San Francisco in this one I'm
usually wrong so I I do kind of think
San Francisco has the better team the
more balanced team but I really think
it's gonna the first quarter is gonna
really be a key I don't think Kansas
City can fall behind by ten by seventeen
like they have in these if they do that
it'll it would they will not come back
yeah but Kansas City in San Francisco
wins the toss defers Kansas City scores
the first time out of the body it'll be
very very interesting this one's been
tough one for me to call but I see the
possibility of a repeat of Super Bowl
five where the MVP comes from the losing
team that the 49ers win but nobody
stands out statistically in Patrick
mahomes is the guy who was the best
player of the game and they give him the
MVP even though the 49ers win wow that's
interesting
you like that like would you ever vote
for the MVP on the losing team of a
Super Bowl I don't think so because I
don't know how unless it's just such a
dominant performance but I don't see how
you can be the most valuable if your
team doesn't win Yeah right it's the way
I feel about it - its it's tough to make
that call well coach we appreciate you
hanging around for a full half hour with
us today Hall of Fame head coach Tony
Dungy we already missed our weekly weird
days watching football to be back here
though before we know
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports